young pioneer Alexandria Kazi Cortez is
a member of Congress but would make a
fantastic bolshevik if she decides to
change careers it's not enough she's
telling us to oppose the president's
immigration policies you also need to
destroy anyone who's even remotely
connected to securing the border
ecommerce company Wayfarer is providing
beds for a new immigrant holding
facility in Texas today some employees
walked out in protest of that Cascio
Cortez endorsed their efforts between at
this quote this is what solidarity looks
like maybe an actual boycott the snack
foods that ice
stalks and vending machines Elizabeth
Warren meanwhile is entering tonight's
debate with a fresh proposal to
completely decriminalize it illegal
illegal border crossings which is of
course completely insane sneaking into
America illegally would no longer be
illegal but what happened to the country
if we did that melissa frances Cohoes
outnumbered as well as after the ballot
box business we're always grateful to
have her on the show Melissa thanks for
coming on so first to Alexandria Kazuya
Cortez what do you make of this she's
saying that anybody who does business
with ice in effect should be punished I
mean it's it's idiotic the CEO wafers a
public company first of all they're
losing money their CEO doesn't get to
make decisions like that he has a legal
fiduciary responsibility to do best with
the shareholders money it's not his
money he can't make decisions based on
his own politics or his own definition
of morality he has to try to make money
for his shareholders it's against the
law for him to do what she wants him to
do to turn down business especially
given the fact that the company is
losing money now let's talk about the
Elizabeth Warren in this other proposal
that we're going to hear more about
tonight at those debates if you tuned in
where they're saying if you cross the
border it shouldn't be illegal guess
what if somebody's coming here to seek
asylum it's because the rule of law in
their home country has broken down to
the point where they no longer feel safe
they are coming to this country because
the rule of law works and keeps them
safe so how is breaking the law
how
helping those people who are coming here
for laws and security these are both
really stupid ideas how does taking away
furniture help children how does taking
away laws help children it doesn't you
know what our lawmakers have massively
failed us this is a huge problem that is
enormous because it has festered for so
long there is no easy way to solve it
it's gonna take a whole bunch of
solutions and here's the thing Tucker I
mean what if every time we interviewed a
lawmaker what if you and I took this
pledge and everybody else and Shep and
Shawn and Rachel and Anderson what if we
all said that every time you interview a
lawmaker you say name one thing you've
opposed before that you're willing to
give and put on the table as a gesture
to get the ball rolling you can't name
what you want in return
because you know what everyone's gonna
have to work together to come to a
solution that picture of the dead child
is really heartbreaking but everybody
looks at it and they see someone
different to blame we can all look at it
and see that it's total failure on the
part of America so look at that picture
and ask lawmakers what is it that you're
willing to put on the table with nothing
in return you won't look weak you'll
look strong what do you think don't you
think that would work
it might I mean I personally think that
the people in charge of the country need
to first care about the country I'm in a
country now Japan whose leaders whatever
their flaws care about the country of
Japan there's no immigration to Japan
because they don't think it's good for
the country there's also no litter here
and no crime so every priority on both
sides of the divide here politically the
basic priorities are the same which is
take care of the country I don't see
almost anybody in Congress who's putting
America now literally America's interest
no I don't know I don't think so either
I agree with you but I think this would
expose them because I think both sides
have let this problem fester and it's
become a great political thing for them
it's become a way to hit the other side
I mean when you have somebody proposing
that anybody who comes into this country
legally illegally suddenly it's illegal
that doesn't make any sense so there
obviously
trying to do anything real they're
trying to make a political point so
let's challenge them to actually fix the
problem or shut up and get out of the
way amen
listen Frances thanks very much for that